that being gay has opened me helps me
understand how one can be misunderstood
how you can be trapped in the lens of
somebody else's stereotype whether it's
all kids are like that or all teenage
boys are like that are all gay people
are like that and it's made me I think
more compassionate not necessarily any
less some strict with my sons but
certainly more understanding I think of
the challenges that they're facing and
and really the challenges that I as a
parent and facing to make sure we grow
them into fine young men and you know
teenage boys are you know it's day by
day on that score my younger son tried
out for the local baseball team we moved
recently a couple years ago now from
Cambridge which is when I was in the
legislature where I served to Jamaica
Plain Massachusetts and I live in a part
of jamaica plain that was over a lot of
Dominicans lived on Dominican folks
lived and a lot of lesbians so we had
the best little league team in the city
it was the place everybody wanted to
come and the tryouts happened my son
made the team he was thrilled the second
day of practice comes home excited third
day of practice comes home and he's in
tears and asked Nathaniel what's what's
the problem and he wouldn't didn't want
to talk to me about it you know 13e you
know he's a tough kid he's not going to
let anything let me see any
vulnerability or weakness I call this
coach in his coach explain you know I
was going to call you Jarrett the
baseball team where they were practicing
today there were a couple of other kids
that Nathaniel was trying to make
friends with and they were calling each
other gay and Nathaniel in the attempt
to make friends offered up that his two
dads were gay not understanding that
they were using the term gay in a way
that was derogatory making fun at each
other and so when he offered that up
they clearly ate that up and began to
ridicule him
which totally hurt disoriented defeated
him in his intentions and his new you
know new neighborhood new community new
team to be a valued member and embraced
member of his baseball team and that was
very hard it was hard because you know
we live in Massachusetts we live in a
place where we're nearly legally equal
but there's no court and there's no
legislature that can change how
Nathaniel's treated on the baseball
diamond
you know it's wonderful living in
Massachusetts because we are we have the
option of full equality of legal
equality and that's it's important to
distinguish between legal equality the
state level and full legal equality
which would include federal recognition
of our marriage of our family which
isn't the case because of the federal
Defense of Marriage Act but at the state
level for sure we are about as equal in
Massachusetts as anywhere else in the
United States is a gay family and what
does that mean well it means that you
know I am as it is I have the same
challenges and frustrations raising kids
but I also have the same rights that are
necessary for me to be able to take care
of my kids whether it's access to school
records whether it's being able to get
the hospital to take care of them if my
husband's name is first on the list i'll
still be recognized because we are
legally married if i were to die we
wouldn't it faced additional state tax
burdens because our relationship isn't
recognized countless ways six seven
hundred different ways we are held to be
equal in Massachusetts that I wouldn't
be in other statements very important